Okay.
I think we'll uh
we'll kind of get started.
Um
So, I'm uh Mark Pollefeys, um professor
here in the department, but I'm also
um I am in the Department of Computer
Science, but I'm also working at uh
Microsoft uh leading the Spatial AI Lab.
Um and uh
Oyer is uh Oyer Mes is one of the
researchers uh in the lab. There, he's
in particular really driving things
forward on robot learning and so on, and
we identified that there was actually
this was
something that was missing at ETH in the
curriculum a
uh a course really focused on robot
learning.
And so um we had uh
we decided that then Oyer uh could
essentially uh fill in that gap. Um and
so that's uh what you'll have here. So,
I'll serve as the mentor also for the
course. A lot of people from the lab
will actually also help as TAs and so
on. Um so, you'll also see there will be
some robots to play with actually during
the course, all these kind of things.
So, we've taken care of all those things
on on the ETH side. Um so, um although
Oyer from
at Microsoft will essentially teach this
course, it's fully integrated uh within
ETH and we'll have all of the usual
things and resources and so on.
Okay. And so, without further ado, uh
I'll I'll uh let uh Oyer kind of um uh
take over. Um may maybe one one more
small thing. Yeah. Uh so, Oyer was
um you know, did his PhD not too far
from here um
uh at um
uh in um
uh where is it again? Uh Freiburg. Oh,
you have it there. Uh Okay, perfect.
Yeah, in Freiburg.
Uh wait. Uh there.
Um and um uh
and then essentially after that did his
uh postdoc uh at Berkeley uh worked
there with Sergey Levine and and people
like that. Uh and then now he's uh here
in Zurich. And so, yeah, I'll leave it
at that.
Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> Um yeah, thanks everybody for for coming
to this first lecture. Do you hear me
okay also in the back?
Yes? Awesome.
Uh yeah, really appreciate you all
coming. I'm very excited for this
course.
Also appreciate you all coming despite
the the weather today.
As as Mark pointed out, I spent the last
2 year in in sunny California. And the
winters there were definitely different
to the winters in Zurich.
But still super excited to be here.
And you know,
talk a little bit about robot learning.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, maybe like I will today start first
with some of the course logistics. So,
if in case you need to reach me, uh my
contact details are here. Um but more
importantly, like first I want to talk a
little bit about
like to show you the why behind this
course.
So, the the collage here represents
essentially
work I have been doing
during my time in uh
Framework, in Berkeley, and also now in
Zurich. And so, these are not really
just like cool demos, but they are like
experimental results of the very robot
learning frameworks that we will
be studying in this course in this
semester.
Um so, from the drawer opening task here
with the Google robot on the right, uh
to mobile navigation, well, I think the
pointer doesn't do,
or drone flying.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh we will use the same
imitation learning and reinforcement
learning algorithms. Um or these are
using the same algorithms that you will
be implementing in this
semester. first with
the individual homework assignments and
later with real world
group projects.
Of course managing a course at this
scale is a massive team effort
and I'm incredibly fortunate to be
joining this semester by a team of
exceptional TAs.
Our team includes
Alexi, Jonas, Liam, Nicola, Tianxu,
Simon, Nicole and Sado as well as Carl
who's on the next slide
and they are working really hard to help
create and validate the homework
assignments. And they will also be your
main point of contact to answer
questions and help with um
the exercises on the Thursday sessions.
Maybe like the TAs that are here you can
stand up like so people can see who you
are.
And by the way like
we still have open TA positions because
like the course seems to be very
popular. We have 290 enrolled students
right now.
So if you're interested in helping also
TA this course
especially if you're like still a master
students please also contact
Liam, Jonas, Alexi
and so forth. We will be excited to to
talk to you about
if you want if you can help us with the
TAs.
So
without further ado the plan for today
is to cover like the course logistics
first
and the goals the goals and logistics
Um, then um, a little bit on like why
you should like study robot learning.
Um, so, um, this course is not really,
uh, about spending all all the semester
just like training VLAs,
uh, etc., but it is, um, trying to be a
comprehensive curriculum where we will
first kind of cover the basic
algorithmic frameworks, as I said
before, from imitation through
reinforcement learning, um,
and [clears throat] also expose you to
different tools and philosophies, uh,
also in, uh, robot learning. And so, um,
we will cover, uh, fundamentals first in
the first kind of half, uh,
uh, in the first part of the course, um,
and then we will also have some
hands-on, uh, experience with the real
robots,
um, and we will also cover, uh, frontier
models and more advanced topics, uh, in
robot learning towards the end of the
um, of the course.
But, uh, really most important goal of
this, uh, course is to inspire you. Um,
robot learning is really a fascinating,
um, field because, like, you get exposed
to everything from,
uh, from frontier high-level frontier
modeling down to like low-level PD
control that actually moves the robot
hardware, um, and in computer vision and
NLP, as you all have seen, we have see,
uh, we have witnessed this like massive
paradigm shift, right? Where we've went
from, um, like individual, uh, kind of
like tailored specialist models that
were doing like all these things, like
translation, object detection, image
captioning, and so forth, um, to kind of
this more, um, transformer-based
foundation models,
um, and uh, like this lead to
essentially like the chat GPT moment,
right? In
uh, computer vision and and like in AI
in general, right? And in robotics, we
are kind of standing on the shoulder of
giants, right? So, we have decades of
incredible progress in model-driven
control
and more recently we have begun
>> [clears throat]
>> adopting the like transformative power
of
many of the advances made in the other
communities like in vision and NLP.
And as you can see like by by this arrow
like
and specifically the word you in in it
in the slide, we are now kind of on the
verge of the chat GPT moment for
robotics and
my hope is that by the end of the
semester
some of you will find this field
interesting enough to
to essentially like join and you know,
help us build it.
All right. So,
before we start talking about robot
learning, I will briefly cover the
course structure. So, we will here is
the the website with all the
information.
On Mondays, we will have
first around 45 minutes of lecture
usually instruct given by me where we
will as I said before cover like a lot
of the
algorithmic framework and fundamentals
followed by paper discussion
from
like student-led paper discussions. I
will talk about this in the next slide
in a second.
And then throughout the course at the
end of this, we will have
guest kind of lectures or spotlights
not maybe not every week but on most of
the weeks we will have like around 20
minutes or something
from like different um
researchers from both industry and
academia kind of presenting some of
their
advances and cool work and
trying to kind of fit them like
topic-wise that
Um, that these researchers more or less
like um, are experts in the uh,
field or topic that we will be covering
like that particular day.
Um, on Thursday uh, we will have the TA
led uh, practice session. Um,
here um,
we will cover essentially the homework
assignments.
Um, discuss or give feedback, um,
answer any questions you might have
about the homeworks.
Um,
on some weeks like the TAs will also
cover the solutions for the previous uh,
assignments
and so forth.
And uh, in general um, there will be
uh, four assignments first uh,
individual assignments before we move to
the uh, group projects with the real
robots.
Um, so for the paper discussions we will
be doing on Mondays.
Um, in the
project website uh, for each uh, session
um, you will find uh, around three
different papers.
And um,
how we will try to do this, we will see
if uh, it works with the number of
students we have. Um, but the idea is
that we will more or less have groups of
four students.
Um, and we will essentially have um,
like one group that kind of will present
the paper and another group that will
you know, be kind of reviewer two or
will try to like point out maybe some
um,
like some things that they could have
done better or critique a little bit the
the paper.
Um,
and so this will be around approximately
15 minutes per paper um, ideally.
Uh, and um,
so I have put the link um, on the
website, but if you uh,
if you want you can also just scan the
QR code here right now.
Um, this will take you to the form where
you can sign up for
one of the papers um that you like, that
you would like to
uh present that day um and during the
semester. And you can also um decide if
you want to more be on the group that
presents the paper or yes, we have a
question.
This is separate from the project group,
yes.
Yes, so this will be like essentially
like after the lecture like today, you
know, like I will be talk Well, today
there is no reading club but like
starting next week after the first 40-45
minutes of lecture, um this will be
student-led uh paper discussion.
Yes.
Yeah.
Sorry, I didn't get the question. How
many papers?
Just one. One. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So, I I think also because
of the high number of students, I don't
know how many will keep enrolled but
uh I think like it should be one.
I mean, obviously like I would recommend
everybody to like read all the papers
that are recommended for
uh for all um
uh lectures but in terms of like kind of
presenting with your team, it will be
just one. Cuz
um there are also like other like
assignments so, you know, doesn't make
sense to uh ask too much.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um
speaking of uh individual homework,
um we as I said before, we have um
divided the
uh course into two parts. In the first
half, um
you will be uh working on individual
homework assignments. Um
and here are more or less the the topics
and the dates
uh you will have to uh submit um these
assignments.
Uh we will use an autograder
um to check um your assignments.
And um
yes, I think the first assignment should
be out by the end of this lecture. Is
this correct?
Yes, the TA says yes.
Cool.
Uh and here is the uh GitHub link uh
where
uh it will be published. But this you
can also find on the project course.
Maybe one small advice um
for the homework uh
assignment, um
this all a lot of the homeworks, maybe
not the first one, but um
they are based on training like
uh neural networks,
uh robot control policies, and uh
although we try to make the homeworks
faster to train by making the
environments more simple, the domain
simple, that you know, like it doesn't
require a data center to run this model.
Um
in general, these still take some
uh time to train. So, my advice uh is
that please don't start the night before
the deadline
uh trying to solve like your exercise
because
you know, your model might not
um have enough time to train or converge
or maybe you made a mistake, you need to
like retrain your model. So,
uh like please like um start before like
the the deadline night.
Um
for the course grading, um I'm sure
everybody will do amazing uh for
everything. Um we have decided more or
less to divide this um
in around 20% for the paper uh
presentation
and discussion, uh 40% for the practical
homework, and uh 40% for the group
project that will that you will do in
the second half of the course
with the real hardware.
So there is no final exam
but you know
there is like you know some some work to
do so you kind of get familiarized with
all the
frameworks and and tools and research in
robot learning.
Um
Yes.
So
feedback is really welcome. It's my
first time teaching a course at this
scale.
Also for our TAs it's the first time and
we are really trying hard to
you know offer a great course
but for sure we will make some mistakes
because you know we are
making things as we are going
we will try to send every few weeks
surveys to like a subset of the students
to kind of get feedback on you know what
are we doing well what can we improve
and so on. So yeah just wanted to let
you know that
also because of the large number of
students it makes things a bit more
more difficult maybe to scale but we are
trying our best and hope that we can we
will offer a great course.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> All right and with this
I think we have covered the logistics.
Oh there's one more question.
Sorry we I need the microphone I don't
hear.
Yeah just because it's always a problem
with project based courses um
how is the compute situation, let's say?
Yeah, um, so for the first, um,
like for the first homework assignments,
the
um, you should not need like a lot of
compute. It should be possible to run
these on like a
like like a desk like a PC.
Um, I think for the second half of the
course where we will do like the real
robot group projects, um, we are trying
to get access to
uh more compute um so that we could also
do a little bit more,
you know, like
use bigger models and, you know, do a
bit more cool stuff, um, but we are
working on it.
Um, so you said that like in the Excel
sheet it says presenting group and what
it like which size group.
Should we sign up for groups like on a
platform or how do you manage that?
For the uh read it for the paper
discussion?
>> Yeah.
The question is if you should sign up
for one group? No, the question is that
like should we just write our names or
should we like I don't know right make a
group on a Google Docs or I don't know
how you work with that. I think you can
just write your name, I think.
It's it's fine. Let's not over
complicate it.
>> Like this is different from, you know,
the groups that you will be doing later
for the real robot like project.
It's just like to present a paper.
Could you maybe talk a bit more about
the final project like what it's going
to be or like what roughly the goal is
there?
Uh
yeah, um,
so
uh
I think I have a slide later, but
um essentially we have
uh purchased like a fleet of 50 SO101
robots
um thanks to the generosity of Mark.
Um and um so these are like really cool
robots um it's like from from Leo Robot
um which also have like a puppeteering
setup. Um so it's really easy also, you
know, to collect like some
demonstrations if you want to like uh
like try to learn a new task with the
robot. Um
we [clears throat] will um the idea is
that we will offer a set of canonical
projects.
>> [clears throat]
>> Sorry. Uh just because the load for the
TAs would be way too big if we did like
50 different like uh group projects with
these robots. Um but we will try to make
uh to find a way um so that there is
like these set of canonical projects
that, you know, you um kind of should be
like more or less straightforward um to
implement and you get some hands-on
experience. Um but ideally we will also
try to give some time in case, you know,
like um you want to
do some more advanced things with it
and, you know, you're like creative and
want to do some uh maybe more more
complex things, we will try to fit this
in also. Um but yeah, we'll we'll get to
that like in around 6 weeks or so. Yeah.
>> Okay, thank you.
All right.
Okay, that's a lot of questions, but
yeah.
So I just want to ask for clarification
on the paper discussions again. So each
group So there is like the criti-
criticizing part and there is the
presentation part. So does each group
has to just choose one of these or does
each group has to present at some point
and then criticize also at some point?
So I think um the original idea is that
you either uh present or criticize. Um I
think we will see how many students are
cuz we have to fit somehow all the
students in this time slot.
So, we will start with that and you
know, if we see that this is not working
out like we can maybe adapt it or
something, but that would be the idea
that you are at least either work on the
um
on one of the teams at least. Yeah.
All right.
Oh, Mark Mark also has a question. No,
no, it was it was to clarify if I think
for the projects we'll talk about it
later also, but but I think the idea was
on the one hand there will be this kind
of technical projects.
You know, that should give you allow you
to get kind of good grades and
everything, but then there will also be
more challenging projects also for some
of you. I know some of you are PG
students also in the class here and so
on. So, depending on where you're at and
and what you're interested in,
you might also be able to do really
projects that go further also if you're
PG student and align maybe with your
research and then we can select an
element of that that would fit as a
project. So, we'll have that flexibility
um to do one of the canonical projects
uh with your team or actually also to
kind of go for something that's more
challenging that's maybe you need
already more background to do it or you
need resources that we might not be able
to provide,
uh but if you already as a PG student
have a robotic platform available, then
maybe it makes sense to try something on
that. So, that's that's a little bit
the way we're thinking about it at this
point. Mhm.
Thanks.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right. Um
so, now that we have cleared the
logistics, um
I want to move on a little bit into
um robotics and robot learning. So,
uh I'm going to start with a little bit
of history um because as you all know,
robots really have um long captured like
our minds like um
for kind of serving like as a blueprint
for for what we are like building uh
today in terms of robots, right? And uh
this timeline is just It's like, you
know, like a cinematic timeline,
um but it's also a sort of like a
history of
like the expectations,
um
our evolving expectations for like
autonomy. Um and so in the early uh 20th
century, uh
like we started with like characters
like the Q automaton or um like in
Metropolis.
Uh so these are like really old. It's
like uh
um
over [clears throat] um
around like 100 uh years old, right?
And um
by the '60s, uh Rosie the Robot um is
kind of like a very popular um character
which shifted um you know, like the
first um like the first robots were kind
of showing more like the industrial
automation automation kind of
like a blueprint, right? And then
the our expectations shifted more
towards utility and service. And then
with Star Wars with R2-D2 and so on, um
like we started to think of robots um
more
um as social agents with distinct
personalities instead of just like
tools.
Um and you know, kind of like more uh
collaborative um
uh personalities that then also led to
things like Wall-E, right?
But
but moving to reality, like why do we
actually build robots?
So, while science fiction kind of, you
know, explores our imagination, the the
why is um
kind of grounded in the necessity um
and the tremendous potential that robots
have for good in our society. Um because
we are moving towards a future where um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh autonomous systems perform tasks that
are fundamentally uh either dangerous
um or um
kind of distant and demanding. So, this
can be uh, from the frontiers of like,
you know, interplanetary exploration um,
to, you know, helping explore uh,
like the depths of our oceans, um,
where, you know, these are really
hostile environments
uh, for humans to survive in.
Um,
and [clears throat] also robots
allow us to um, automate um,
>> [clears throat]
>> some like, like, let's say dirty and
dangerous jobs,
uh, like, let's say, underground mining,
for example.
Um,
or they can help after um, natural
disasters and sort of like search and
rescue operations
um, to keep like people out of harm's
way.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> as well as um, they also have a lot of
applications in in in like in our health
health care system and in medicine,
right?
Um,
but perhaps more more critically, we are
also looking at robots to solve um, like
a
um, like kind of like a looming social
crisis because as our western uh,
societies grow older,
um, we will need more people to um, help
us um, and having
um,
robots that can assist and sort of
perform personalized
uh, assistance and care at home
uh, will hopefully makes our lives also
a little bit easier and reduce the
burden on on our health care systems.
Um,
I want to start now with um,
uh, a video that maybe some of you
already have seen.
Um,
this is, is it playing?
This is Shakey the robot.
So, to understand where we are now in
robotics, I think it's good to kind of
see where it all started. At SRI, we are
experimenting with a mobile robot. We
call him Shakey.
Our goal is to give Shakey some of the
abilities associated with intelligence,
abilities like planning and learning.
Even though the tasks we give Shakey
seem quite simple, the programs needed
to plan and coordinate his activities
are complex.
The main purpose of our research is to
learn how to design these programs so
that robots can be employed in a variety
of tasks ranging from space exploration
to industrial automation.
Shakey operates in this experimental
environment of rooms, doorways, and
simple objects.
The top lens belongs to Shakey's
television camera. He uses it to obtain
visual information about his own
environment or other objects.
>> These walls were made high enough so
that Shakey cannot see over them with
his television camera.
Shakey uses these feelers or cat
whiskers to tell him if he has bumped
into anything.
He can push objects with his push bar.
The programs controlling Shakey reside
in a large computer with 300,000
36-bit words of storage.
>> Um so, this was kind of like the state
of the art to the computer over a radio
link. Wait.
This was kind of the state of the art um
in 1966. This was a robot developed in
Stanford. Um and um
um it essentially was like planning
everything. It kind of didn't follow a
script, but it was like doing planning.
Um Are any of you familiar with the A*
path planning algorithm?
Well, oh, amazing.
Um so, that algorithm was actually
developed for this robot. Uh fun fact.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so
yeah, um
so this this is kind of where it all
started.
Shaky was doing the maybe many of you
know like this sense plan act kind of
loop.
As you as you've just seen it had like
this this TV
camera to kind of like do the visual
scene analysis and then um
it had like sonar range finders
to detect the distances to all
and
it was like essentially um
using A* for you know minutes or
half an hour an hour before it decided
you know like what is the next move I
can do and then you know push the
objects and so on.
Um
sorry.
and from there like I think in the kind
of 70s, 80s and 90s as you probably all
know like we kind of moved towards more
of this like industrial automation
where you know we use like like kind of
like industrial robotic arms to for
manufacturing
like let's say a car assembly and so
forth and these actually don't work too
different from like Shaky the robot in
the 60s it's very very similar. Um they
sense the world
um plan a geometric
plan in in like their known map and then
act with like really high precision.
Um and this is like
this has been incredibly successful but
only in structured environments because
essentially like they are state
machines. So they're only as good as the
logic that we can program into them and
these robots are more or less like you
know maybe now less but um, they used to
be like very very blind. Um,
so if, you know,
a part on the assembly line like, uh,
kind of like change, like they would not
really like, uh, adapt, uh, to those
changes.
And so, the course, um, the goal in our
course is to move beyond these like
closed world assumption. Uh, we want to
explore how robots can move, uh, past
rigid state transitions, uh, and instead
kind of like use data-driven,
uh, algorithms, um, to handle like, uh,
you know, edge cases of the real world.
Um, maybe as an, kind of like a more
visual example, um,
you might know some of these videos from
from YouTube. Um,
uh, for example, these are like, uh,
some humanoid, uh, robots. Um, some of
them also from Boston Dynamics, uh,
which are like represent some of the
most impressive hardware, uh, that we
have built. Um, but even with like
really world-class engineering, um, they
typically have been relying on, um,
near-perfect state estimation, right?
Um, and so,
this is like also, um,
um, these are videos from the DARPA
Robotics Challenge in 2015, where it
kind of like
the, uh, humanoid robotics, um, kind of
started to gain more momentum. And, uh,
I mean, it's it's really interesting to
see like how even simple tasks as like,
you know, opening a door or like opening
a valve like makes robot like flip
backwards.
It's [laughter] like
uh,
it's it's it's it's really funny.
Um, and then, a few years later, like
this is, uh, Boston Dynamics, um,
the Atlas robot.
Um,
you can see
you already see like they have QR codes
all over the place because, you know,
that's what they used to kind of
like have this like perfect like world
model or like state estimation to
understand where is everything at all
times and if you are even like you know
a few centimeters off like you know like
catastrophic things can happen.
And um
you know even like more recently um
um
yeah.
Ouch.
Um similar um issues also happen when
they do like things like parkour, right?
So these are like really more or less
almost blind movements or they assume
perfect knowledge of like all the
environment and uh even the slightest
like um
like error in perception or or planning
results in you know these these robots
like uh falling falling and you know
breaking like their expensive hardware.
Um this brings us to uh Moravec's
paradox um who was a faculty at CMU um
who formulated um this paradox back back
in 1988 um and this kind of like
captures why it is like so challenging
uh why robotics is so challenging
compared to other branches in AI.
Um so he observed that essentially
abstract thinking
so the high-level reasoning we uh humans
um typically find difficult to do,
right? Uh like complex mathematics or
like strategic planning or you know
playing chess or something is actually
relatively easy for an AI to compute um
and we have had algorithms that you know
beat like human chess players and so
forth uh for decades now. Um but the
real paradox is um sensory motor skills,
right? So basic physical interaction
that animals and even toddlers find
effortless uh is incredibly hard for AI.
Um so um
because essentially there is like no
training data. They cannot like crawl
the internet to understand like how to,
you know, like grasp a bottle and and
and drink from it. Um and you can see
this like a little bit on this this
images over here.
Um so
uh here is an example uh from my PhD uh
2019. I was trying
to grasp this this mug desperately with
my PR2 robot in Freiburg.
And
uh you know, this was based on point
cloud observations, you know, analytical
grasp pose estimation and whatnot.
And you see like it doesn't doesn't
really work. And here, boom.
>> [laughter]
>> It It breaks the the the the mug in two
cuz it grasped too hard.
So
uh
Yeah, we've made some progress in the
since then, but it's it's really like
fascinating, right? And then you you you
see like this uh orangutans like they
can even use like tools just like by
looking at others and imitating and it
looks so effortless, right? But this
even this basic just like grasping a a
a simple mug with a robot hand is like
so difficult.
Um
Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> So this brings us to the core of this
course. So really if we want to move
past um this like, you know,
uh rigid state of machines on the
factory floor, we need like a different
approach.
And uh robot learning is the study um of
algorithms that enable a robot to um
acquire [clears throat] new skills or
adapt to an unstructured environment um
by learning from data and experience
um rather than relying on, let's say,
like explicit uh or hand-coded
programming.
And um this diagram like I tried to
illustrate this a little bit um
on the challenge we face. So on the one
side, we have kind of the robotics,
uh which is like rooted in the physical
world, um and
traditional, you know, we kind of
traditional and we engineer solutions to
it, we build models for it, and so on.
And on the other hand, we have machine
learning, uh which has really like
thrived in, you know, the digital world,
um with data-driven solutions um that
can generalize with massive amounts of
data. And robot learning is essentially
the synthesis of these two. So, it's
bringing about um it's about bringing
generalization into the physical world
uh to solve problems that are too
complex to uh engineer uh manually.
And um how do we actually bridge this
gap um by
uh of Moravec's paradox? So, the answer
really lies in robot learning. So, in
this course, we will define robot
learning um simply as solving robotics
via machine learning.
And so, on the left um here I have put
the pillars of robotics, um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, let's say perception and control.
These are, let's say, the what of like
how the robot sees the world and how the
robot physically
uh
moves within it. And as I said before,
um
like historically, we've like done a lot
of like great like model-based work on
this. And on the right, we have the how,
the machine learning. Um this is like
the toolbox we will try to use um to,
you know, fill some some gaps with this
data-driven approaches.
And we will look look into imitation
learning, reinforcement learning,
representation learning, and all these
things from
uh machine learning.
Now, before we get deeper into the
algorithms, maybe let's um
talk about how we define robots.
Um so, on the left, we have dishwasher.
Uh in the middle, we have the da Vinci,
the surgical medical robot. And on the
right, we have chat GPT on the phone. Um
maybe um you could like talk for a 30
seconds to your neighbor and discuss if
you think that any of these are a robot
and if so, why?
Somebody wants to share what they have
discussed very quickly.
Alexa, just put the mic to someone you
find.
Oh, Elisabetta.
Uh yeah, we were discussing a bit and uh
yeah, we think that dishwasher
definitely it is a robot because it kind
of change the physical state of the
world by operating something. ChatGPT
definitely it is not a robot in a
traditional sense because you can have
some some intellectual uh
interaction with it, but then the word
stays as it is.
And while the
the machine that doctor uses, it kind of
depend on whether it is only analytical
or whether you can actually perform
something by using it and uh if it is
actually changing the world, but if
you're controlling the machine yourself,
then yeah, it is not really a robot
because it's not automating the task.
Yeah.
Yeah, thanks. Yeah, that's that's that's
really a
great summary. So, you correctly
identified, right? So, for like the
surgical robot like this is essentially
like a teleoperation. I mean, it does
like some correction for like shaking of
the humans and so on, but it's not like
autonomous in a sense. It's not like,
you know, doing the search surgery like
instead of the doctor, right? And for
like the ChatGPT on the phone, like it
doesn't have like an embodiment,
although it has like very like
high-level like reasoning uh
capabilities, right? Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, yeah, in robot learning, we are in
really interested in the intersection.
We really want to arrive reliability of
an appliance, um, the physical dexterity
of a surgical arm,
uh, and general-purpose reasoning of a
foundation model.
Um, good. Uh,
we'll continue. Where's my pointer not
doing?
So, this this brings us to the
fundamental question of why don't we
already have autonomous robots in our
homes, for example?
Um, so, for this is a video from 2007,
um, from Stanford, um, and it shows a
robot called the PR1, um,
performing a bunch of useful everyday
tasks, um, such as tidying up, um,
a room. And, you know, maybe for those
of you who are not familiar with uh,
robotics,
these tasks really seem easy and
trivial, um,
but, you know, as I said before, like,
they are actually quite challenging for
AI models at as it requires like
common-sense understanding about how to
operate in unstructured environments.
Um,
in reality,
this robot was not autonomous, um, but
it was being teleoperated, um,
which, if you think about it, is
actually a great sign because it means
that we have had the hardware to
perform, you know, like, similar like
tasks, like, tidy up tidying up a room,
uh, since 2007,
um, but what has been missing is
essentially the the software or the
brain of this to make it autonomous,
right?
Um,
while the PR1 in 2007 showed us what is
possible, um, still the hardware
landscape has fundamentally shifted, um,
on two critical fronts since then.
On the left, you see like the explosion
of humanoid robots with mood we have
moved from let's say like isolated like
research prototypes to really a
competitive industry of sophisticated
even commercially available
platforms from companies like Figure,
Tesla, Boston Dynamics and so on.
And these are like embodiments that are
capable of doing now way more dexterous
tasks than the PR1 that I was just
showing from 2007.
But [clears throat] as we discussed
before like a robotic platform without
a brain is like essentially just a
puppet. So this is why the image on the
right is um
perhaps maybe even more more important
or or at least as as important as the
hardware because this represents also
like um
like the progress we have made in AI in
general by the availability of you know
massive compute through like improved
GPUs and and so on, right? So back then
in 2007 like we simply didn't have the
processing power
to train models that could you know that
would scale to the required like
generalist intelligence.
While today's we we read today we really
have like this clusters that run
[clears throat]
this like massive like scaling laws that
work for NLP and vision for example.
Um
We've looked at hardware and compute,
but now we also need to talk about
you know like the data that kind of like
fuels all of this, right? To understand
why we had the ChatGPT moment in
language, but we are still waiting for
it in robotics. You have to look at the
sheer scale of information being
consumed. To make these numbers a bit
more easier to interpret, I tried
calculating the average time it would
take a human a single human
to read or process this entire data
sets.
So, um so ImageNet it would take around
2 years like constantly just reading
like the training set, right? And
ImageNet is like now like quite uh it's
quite some time ago.
Um
GPT-2
uh which is a model that still, you
know, by AI standards like doesn't show
maybe some of this emergent like
capabilities uh from like later models,
um but still is like a decently sized uh
model, it would take around 60 years um
to read its entire training corpus.
Um and well, like this circles are not
really to scale. I'm sorry about that.
But Llama 3 um it would be like 90,000
years, right?
Um
so, [clears throat]
um yeah, so this really also like is
equally um shows you like how progress
in like AI has driven
um
in this recent advances.
In terms of
Um finally, we come to the models
themselves. Um
I won't go into too much detail here,
but um we've really see like uh as you
all know like a breathtaking
uh progression in algorithmic
intelligence over the last uh few years.
You know, we started with um computer
vision um
moving from simp simple classification
um
to uh models that uh really like
parse the world with near uh
pixel-perfect accuracy. Um then came
AlphaGo
uh which proved that uh reinforcement
learning could uh master
um
uh long-term strategic strategic
reasoning, Uh um,
out
>> [clears throat]
>> outperforming world champions. And now
we even have multi-model models like,
uh, Gemini. Um,
um, so this is really like impressive,
right? And um,
I think in,
uh, even like, maybe like one one thing
to note in AlphaGo is that,
uh, it's not like a thing for the
AlphaGo, it's not just about like that
this model was able to beat, um, like
the the world champion, but I think for
like scientists, like the most
interesting part of that was like this,
uh, move 37. Um, maybe some of you have
heard it. This was like a move that, um,
like the model did like during, I think,
the second, uh, match um, that was like
so alien that first people thought that,
uh, you know, it hallucinated or made a
mistake, but then realized that it was
kind of like a new strategy that, you
know, it came up with by itself, um,
that no other human had, uh, thought of
doing, uh, before.
And so essentially, um, I think for
robotics, we also want to move a little
bit from, you know, this hand-coded er-
era to the discovery era, uh, where
robots solve physical problems in ways
we also haven't maybe imagined ourselves
yet.
And this brings us to the North Star of
the for the field of robot learning,
which is achieving generalist robot
policies.
Um,
as I was saying before, we are moving
away from this era of specialist models
that only know how to do like one task
or one thing, uh, on one specific piece
of hardware. And here the vision is
really to build, uh, like robot
foundation models that can take, you
know, like a large robotic data set as
an input, um, and output actions for any
task, uh, on any robot in any
environment.
And so in this course, we will cover
also like first the algorithmic
frameworks,
uh, used in robot learning before we
dive into some of the more advanced
topics that revolve around answering
some of these questions like where do we
get this data from? How can we model
such large heterogeneous
distributions and so forth.
And
I think you know, if you kind of think
about in the future, we are not there
yet, but think you could imagine a
future where you can just like download
your kind of like robot favorite robot
brain online and then out of the box
your robot starts showing like
reasonable behavior
in a useful manner
you know, for any robot like in a kind
of plug and play
sort of fashion.
To close out this introduction, I want
to show that we aren't just talking
about like a theoretical future,
but this is one that is being actively
built right now. So on the left here,
you can see the Open Next Embodiment
Data Set. This was a massive
international collaboration
with over 200 institutions around the
world in 2004
that was trying to create like let's say
like the ImageNet Data Set for robotics
and we pulled together data from like 22
I think different robot embodiments.
Everything from you know, single arms to
dual arms to navigation robots and so
forth
to essentially
create like this huge data set in like
common like format that allowed
essentially the community to start like
developing and iterating on kind of this
more like generalist robot policies
for the first time and on the right side
you can see
some of these examples some example
models
that are first models that have been
being trained on this data plus some
additional like octo
crude RT2 from Google Pi zero and so
forth.
So,
to finish this introduction, I want to
give you a sneak preview of how
this works.
So, let's start with a basic example.
So, when you typically train a robot
policy,
the model takes us an input a current
image observation and a task
instruction.
Typically, it's a natural language
instruction nowadays.
>> [clears throat]
>> Such as like pick up the spoon and then
the model predicts a sequence of actions
like end effector poses that allows the
robot to achieve this goal.
Now, imagine that instead of doing this
for a single task, we want to train this
on a larger diverse heterogeneous data
set.
So, if we squint a bit and we replace
the robot image with the more regular
internet
image like here like the Statue of
Liberty. And we replace the instruction
with something like caption the scene,
please.
And then the model like answers like oh,
this is this picture depicts the Statue
of Liberty.
This starts to look really familiar for
you know, everybody who has you know,
paid attention in computer vision,
right? Because this you know, starts
looking like a vision language
model.
So,
the key idea
the key idea that much of the latest
advances in robot learning build upon is
that we can view robotics as a similar
problem where we are trying to learn a
powerful a powerful model that maps from
images and instructions to answers, just
that in our case the answers are not
text,
but they are robot actions.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, this means that um
the way we by formulating the robotics
problem as a multimodal sequence
modeling problem,
where we have language tokens, image
tokens, and action tokens, we can also
as an advantage, we can leverage many of
the advancements made in other
communities like in vision and NLP
to drive progress in robot learning.
Okay, so now probably like all of you
are are thinking this.
So, are you saying we can just train a
large transformer on robot data and like
we are done? Is this all this is about?
Not quite.
Luckily.
Um
because there are actually like some key
ingredients and differences
that makes robotics
like harder to just like transfer
all of these like things from from the
other communities, right? Um
like first of all, like the data,
robotic data is is scarce.
We don't have the luxury, although like
we I just said we have like the
ORC-C data set, it's still, you know,
like not
not comparable by any means to the data
sets that the LLMs and so forth are
being trained today. So,
cuz typically a human has to like
teleoperate and supervise the robot, so
collecting robotic data is really really
expensive and very time-consuming, so
that's one of the issues. Um
additionally, [clears throat]
robot data is highly multimodal and
heterogeneous, as instead of just like
training only on natural language, we
have several sensing modalities.
We need to interact with in the real
world.
And every robot has typically different
sensors and actuators.
So that makes it also like more
challenging to scale and to learn from.
Besides,
for robotics, we typically
need to run this in real time. Like we
>> [clears throat]
>> So the model size actually matters. We
can't take, you know, I don't know, like
ChatGPT, like a 100 billion parameter
model and put it on our quadruped
because we
can't like
we don't we can't wait for a minute for,
you know, the ChatGPT API to return an
answer on what the next action should
be. We really need like fast real-time
control.
And [clears throat] finally, evaluating
also
our models with real robotics hardware
is actually quite
tedious and inexpensive, too.
Um
So to begin with, we will
start
in the course looking at the algorithmic
frameworks commonly used in robot
learning today. These can be broadly
classified into two major families that
we will cover extensively throughout the
semester.
On the left, we have imitation learning,
which you can think of as supervised
learning for the physical world. So this
means that given a labeled action data
set,
our goal is to learn a function as is
shown in the example before that maps an
observation to an expert action.
And this traditionally, this framework
assumes that the
inputs are IID, meaning they are
independently and identically
distributed. This means that
each point does not influence any other
data point and that all points come like
from the same data distribution
underlying probability distribution. And
so a lot of like classic machine
learning theory makes this assumption so
that for example if your
training data is IID
then you know like your training and
test performance like
are mathematically like linked for
example.
And then on the right we have
reinforcement learning where the
objective you know changes from like a
behavioral cloning to learning a policy
that given a state like is able to
predict like the next best action. And
this is typically done through trial and
error within an environment to maximize
our reward and
crucially in robotics
here the data is not IID.
So this means that
your actions like when you when you take
an action with your robot this directly
affects future states creating like a
complex feedback feedback feedback loop
>> [clears throat]
>> where as I said like like your action
dictates like what the robot will
perceive next
and also learn next.
Um
So now
bear with me we're going to start slowly
this semester in the first half we will
focus on learning the fundamentals and
the algorithms. We will start
next week covering the basics of robot
control and Markov decision processes
which will provide the mathematical
language we use to describe robot
environment interactions. From there we
will dive deep into the two algorithmic
families I just described imitation
learning
both online and offline reinforcement
learning for robot control.
And to ensure [clears throat] that you
know, you kind of like understand um,
the algorithmic frameworks, um,
we will um, start um, to ask you to
implement these concepts um, in
simulation for your first assignments.
Um, not the first one, but like I think
after the second or third. Um, here uh,
we also um, have created uh, I think
actually Liam created this uh, simulator
in in MuJoCo um, which is using the the
same SO101 arm um, that we will later
use for the real group projects, like
this fleet of 50 robots um, that we
mentioned before.
Um, so that we have uh, some consistency
and you know, maybe then you can reuse
some of the code you wrote for your like
individual homework assignments for uh,
your group project with the with the
real robot because it will be the same
environment.
Um,
in the second half of the course uh, we
will shift gears from the fundamentals
to, you know, kind of the most exciting
research that's happening in the field
today. Uh, I call it scaling robot
learning uh, for lack of a better name.
Um, this is where we will move beyond,
you know, the algorithms for the single
task models and explore a bit how to
build more general purpose uh, robot
brains that we uh, discussed
uh, earlier and we will kind of give an
overview and and dive deep into um,
architectures, [clears throat]
core architectures of the foundation
model era
uh, including generative models,
learning how robots can imagine future
uh, states to plan more effectively,
um,
sequence modeling and um, transformers
uh, where we will
apply or learn the same architectures
and uh, attention mechanisms um, that
power GPT but to the to the world of
physical actions,
um or world models, uh high-level
reasoning, and so forth.
Um and as I said before, oh, the video's
not playing.
Uh as I said before, um this is
essentially the the robotic uh the robot
we will use for the group projects. Um
uh
so this is the SO101. You can see here
someone um is doing the puppeteering uh
to collect some data uh with which then
we can train some things.
Okay. Um
I'll try to cut it short. So,
um
the goal of the course really is to
inspire you um that robot learning is a
cool field. Um we hope that after the
course you will understand uh how we've
gone um
from the 2007 Stanford uh PR1 demo, um
which was doing tidy up tasks, but with
uh teleoperation, to the latest, like
really impressive uh videos you you see
from
uh companies like physical intelligence,
where you know, if you see it, like it's
essentially like the same task, but now
it's like autonomous, right? Uh so I
think that's like super cool to
understand how we've gone from, you
know, um like the teleop demo from 2007
to something that, you know, seems to
start working on on doing like this
task. I think that's uh super uh super
exciting. Similarly, we can also look at
the field of autonomous driving um to
kind of see the same paradigm shift,
where we've moved from the DARPA
self-driving challenge uh in 2005,
uh where vehicles like struggled to uh
navigate deserts um using
um you know, like all these sensors and
kind of like the
uh probabilistic robotics um kind of
like um
uh modeling frame framework um to in
know, the latest demos where the Tesla
uh, the the the new Teslas drive
themselves to the to the new owners uh,
which I think is uh, pretty impressive
that they they can do like automated
delivery. Probably like, you know, only
if you're near if you live close by to
the factory or something, but like still
like it's it's a pretty cool.
Um,
and so [clears throat] we will focus
more on manipulation in this course, but
the same concepts and algorithmic
frameworks that have driven um, progress
uh, also work in in self-driving cars
for sure.
And finally also for humanoids, right?
Where you can see that we have moved
from um, the DARPA Robotics Challenge
which I was showing before in 2015
uh, where even the most advanced uh,
humanoids were struggling with this
basic capabilities of like even opening
a door
uh, or like walking straight um, to um,
the the really like startling dexterity
of like the latest like uh, figure um,
uh, demo
that is like super smooth and and
dexterous.
And
really [clears throat] like
um, and this is like also result from
all this like, you know, robot
foundation modeling.
Um,
and uh, whether it's self-driving
self-driving cars
in a city or a humanoid preparing a
meal, um, the underlying shift is is is
kind of the same where we are moving
from, you know, like hard coding uh, and
um, towards the era of like learned uh,
physical intelligence. And so I hope
that by the end of the course you will
understand like the all the algorithmic
machinery um, that makes this transition
possible.
Um, so I want to finish today's lecture
with this question. Why should you study
robot learning?
Um,
as I said before, um,
the field offers uh, the the field is
incredibly interdisciplinary.
Uh it requires really a broad and unique
skill set.
Um like you are not just like a
mechanical engineer or a software
engineer. Like you are working really
across the entire stack. Um and in this
course like you will touch everything
from high-level reasoning in foundation
models uh and training uh to low-level
like uh PID controllers for the robots,
right? Uh that make the the actual robot
move. Um second, like the advances are
universal. Uh as we see in the
algorithmic frameworks that you learn
here are applicable to almost um all
robotic applications from self-driving
cars to humanoids or robots exploring
this the space. Um so um
and
>> [clears throat]
>> I think
that um
as I said earlier, um these are one of
the most exciting times uh to be working
in in robot learning and maybe the
advances that uh you will make one day
will bring us to the ChatGPT moments for
robotics.
And with this uh thank you for attention
and I hope you enjoy the course.
>> [applause]